Брюссель та Лондон розпочали переговори
щодо умов виходу Великобританії з Євросоюзу.
Загалом спірних питань - більше семисот.
Однак про кілька тем - буде особливо важко домовитися.
"Жорсткий" Brexit" означає кінець вільного руху
грошей, товарів, послуг і робочої сили між Британією та ЄС.
Брюссель вимагає обов'язкового збереження
усіх чотирьох елементів внутрішнього ринку.
Натомість "М'який Brexit" -
це якби Лондон зберіг вільний доступ
до європейського ринку,
а  натомість мусив би дотримуватися усіх правил ЄС
без можливості впливу на них.
Поки не зрозуміло, яку модель Brexit обрали переговорники з Лондона.
Для врегулювання усіх невиконаних фінансових зобов'язань Лондона
перед ЄС у пресі називали суму виплат від 60 до 100 мільярдів євро.
Натомість у британському парламенті звучала сума 184 мільярди фунтів стерлінгів,
які, навпаки, ЄС має повернути Британії.
Стільки Лондон сплатив до спільної скарбниці ЄС від 1973 року.
Прем'єрка Великобританії обіцяла,
що її країна вийде з Європейського Суду .
Прихильники Брексіту вважають такий крок посиленням суверенітету Великобританії.
Однак незрозуміло, яким чином тоді постанови Євросуду щодо прав громадян ЄС
будуть інтерпретуватися у Великобританії,
де мешкають 4 мільйони громадян ЄС.
Водночас у 27 країнах ЄС мешкають близько мільйона британців.
ЄС не хоче, щоб Brexit призвів
до появи стаціонарного прикордонного контролю
між Ірландією і контрольованою Великобританією Північною Ірландією.
Про це заявляв президент Єврокомісії Жан-Клод Юнкер.
Ірландія  буде єдиною країною ЄС,
що матиме спільний сухопутний кордон
з Британією після її виходу з Євросоюзу.
Прикордонний контроль між Ірландією і Північною Ірландією
не здійснюється вже майже 20 років.